[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the Death
Eaters delving into the ranks of
Voldemort's most powerful followers and
uncovering which of these dark witches
and wizards are most dangerous as a
young boy Tom Riddle lacked a normal
range of human emotions however that
certainly didn't mean he was unable to
control people his cunning manipulative
nature eventually meant that he would
form a gang of sorts a group consisting
of his fellow Slytherin students The
Gang That riddle formed was once
described by Dumbledore as a mixture of
the weak seeking protection the
ambitious seeking glory and the thuggish
seeking a leader who could show them
more refined to Cruelty this group were
at that time known as the Knights of
walpurgis but if we fast forward to the
year 1970 32 years after Tom Riddle had
started attending Hogwarts in the
beginning of Voldemort's rise to power
these Knights of all pagers were known
by a different name Death Eaters as far
as dark witches and wizards went the
Death Eaters were the worst this group
was comprised of evil witches and
wizards of all hell-bent on pursuing
their dark Ambitions they were the
followers of Lord Voldemort and they
obeyed his every bidding in an effort to
cleanse The Wizarding World the ultimate
goal being to restore pure blood
Authority and unfortunately Voldemort
managed to amass quite a lot of them
today we'll be taking a look at each and
every one of these followers uncovering
who they were and just how valuable
their contributions may have been to
Voldemort I'd also like to mention that
I'll be sticking to official Death
Eaters only and not just Wizards who
followed Voldemort whether imperious or
not there were many followers of
Voldemort that were not granted deathly
to status or given the dark mark but
were allowed to wear deathy to garments
in order to command the respect they
engendered this group was comprised of
individuals at Voldemort found useful
but did not want to directly associate
himself with a good example of someone
in this category would be fenrir
greybank with all of that established
let's get into it
but before we go any further I'd like to
thank today's sponsor surfshark the
award-winning VPN service that ensures
your privacy and security with surfshark
experience safe and anonymous browsing
while protecting yourself from online
trackers and data collectors but safe
browsing isn't all surfshark offers ever
search for a show on Netflix and been
unable to find it Well Netflix actually
has most shows and movies they just vary
depending on where you are so even
though you're paying for a full
subscription you only get access to a
part of their Library enter surfshark
where magic beckons with their services
you can change your virtual location and
unlock a multitude of movies and shows
that were once beyond your reach with an
astounding 3200 servers spanning across
100 countries you'll be indulging in
lightning fast streaming before you can
say Akio entertainment if this interests
you get an exclusive deal right now
three months completely free just visit
surfshark.deals.hp Theory the links also
in the pinned comment and description
below thanks again to surfshark let's
get back to the video Goyle senior was
the father of Draco Malfoy's Lackey
Gregory Goyle and came from pure blood
roots with the family name notably
appearing on the sacred 28. goyal
senior's capacity is a Death Eater
resided in his Fierce loyalty to
Voldemort he fought for the dark side
during several battles throughout the
series but his most notable contribution
was fighting at the Battle of Hogwarts
alongside his fellow Death Eaters
despite his loyalty however Goyle was
said to be quite unintelligent something
that he inevitably passed down to his
son goyal senior likely died during the
Battle of Hogwarts crab senior was the
father of Draco Malfoy's other main
Lackey Vincent Crabb and was another
Death Eater with Rich pure blood Roots
crab senior's capacity is a Death Eater
was centered around his talents in dark
magic similar to Goyle crab senior was
highly Prejudiced and quite
unintelligent which didn't give his son
Vincent Crabb much of a chance however
it was cunning enough to avoid
imprisonment following Voldemort's first
downfall he notably tries to use the
killing curse on Hermione Granger during
the battle of the Department of
mysteries Mal Saba senior father Junior
was a dark Wizard and one of the
earliest Death Eaters of Lord Voldemort
unfortunately we don't know much about
him including his whereabouts however he
didn't appear to be present during the
second Wizarding War this tells me that
he was either dead or imprisoned in
Azkaban
Wilkes was a Death Eater whose Origins
and blood status are unknown he entered
into Voldemort's service during the
first Wizarding war and was reasonably
scaled in both the dark arts as well as
martial magic Wilkes was said to have
been killed by auras prior to
Voldemort's first defeat Avery Jr was a
pure blood wizard that followed in his
Father's Footsteps to become a Death
Eater his father every senior was one of
the members of Voldemort's original gang
during his time at school during every
Junior's own time at school he was a
close friend of Severus Snape at
Voldemort's rebirth Avery groveled
before the Dark Lord he confess that he
thought Voldemort was finished and
didn't bother seeking him out Avery
weekly begged for forgiveness on behalf
of the Death Eaters but instead of Mercy
Voldemort sadistically tortured him with
the cruciatus curse Avery was involved
in the battle of the Department of
mysteries paired with fellow Death Eater
Walton McNair in their quest to retrieve
the prophecy his weak character lack of
loyalty tells me that he was probably
not a powerful Death Eater not senior
was one of the earliest Death Eaters
joining Voldemort's cause in 1965. Nott
was involved in a number of battles
during the second Wizarding War
including the battle of the Department
of mysteries where he was stunned by
Hermione Granger after attempting to
grab a hold of Harry Potter and his
friends after being stunned not lay on
the floor motionless as shelves of
prophecies collapsed on top of him he
was later sent to Azkaban Rozier senior
father of Evan Rozier was one of the
earliest Death Eaters and to quickly
flocked to the dark side under Lord
Voldemort's Reign aside from
participating in the first Wizarding War
not much is known about rozier's senior
to this day it's unclear whether he's
dead or alive however we do know a
little bit about his son Evan Rozier
because Evan Rozier grew up to become
such a promising dark wizard I'd be
blamed to bet that Rozier senior was
powerful in his own right
Gibbon was a Death Eater known for his
Proficiency in the dark arts
particularly the unforgivable curses
Gibbon notably fought in the battle of
the astronomy tower for which he cast
the dark mark into the sky interestingly
Gibbon lost his life in this battle as a
result of friendly fire when fellow
Death Eater Thor Finn Rowell fired
killing curse at Remus Lupine he missed
hitting Gibbon instead
rabbistan Lestrange was a Death Eater
Infamous for his participation in the
torture of Frank and Alice Longbottom he
committed this atrocity with his brother
rodolfus sister-in-law Bellatrix and
fellow Death Eater Barty Crouch Jr as a
Death Eater rabbistan Lestrange had
significant magical strength and was
well versed in the dark arts his
proficiency with the cruciatus curse is
said to be especially noteworthy
rabbistan participated in many battles
over the course of the first and second
Wizarding Wars including the battle of
the Department of mysteries and battle
of Hogwarts of the Lestrange Brothers he
was said to be the more nervous one
jugson was a dark wizard the Death Eater
who served in the Lord Voldemort during
the second Wizarding War he participated
in several battles including the battle
of the Department of mysteries and
battle of Hogwarts during the former
Jackson was hit with a full-body bind
curse while pursuing Harry Potter
Hermione Granger and Neville Longbottom
however before this happened him and his
partner on the mission entered in
indolahov were able to successfully hit
all three of them with an impediment
Jinx it's also worth noting that jugson
was quite an impatient man who had
little regard for his comrades it's
unclear what happened to jugson after
the war zelwyn was a dark wizard that
served Voldemort's cause during the
second Wizarding war and participated in
a multitude of battles at one point he
was grouped with fellow Death Eater
Travers and sent on a mission to Ambush
Harry Ron and Hermione at the Lovegood
house under a tip from xenophilius
Lovegood zelwyn was a particularly cruel
individual known for beating up and
torturing xenophilius as well as
threatening to mutilate his daughter
Luna Travis on the other hand
participated in both the first and
second Wizarding wars during the first
war he was responsible for murdering the
family of Order of the Phoenix member
Marlene McKinnon tragically the
mckinnons were one of the only Wizarding
families at Voldemort and his followers
were able to completely wipe out in
terms of magical ability Travis was
quite gifted able to cast a diverse
array of dark curses as well as a
multitude of useful charms notably the
human presence revealing spell in
general demeanor Travis was quite a calm
wizard however there was certainly a lot
Brewing beneath the surface he was
absolutely obsessed with blood Purity
and was even somewhat of a xenophobe
electo and Amicus Caro were a brother
sister deathy to Duo that were installed
at Hogwarts as professors following
Voldemort's takeover of the school in
place of defense against the dark arts
Amicus was appointed as the new dark
arts Professor electo on the other hand
was in charge of muggle studies teaching
the subject in an entirely New Way both
siblings were present for most of the
battles that took place over the course
of the second Wizarding war and was said
to be quite magically talented
particularly in the realm of the Dark
Arts with that said however both electo
and Amicus were basted in a duel by the
powerful Minerva McGonagall who forced
them to run off with their arms covering
their heads
Walden McNair was a dark Wizard and one
of Lord Voldemort's earliest Death
Eaters he served as a ruthless servant
of the dark lord through his
participation in both the first and
second Wizarding Wars after Voldemort's
first downfall he worked as an
executioner for the committee for the
disposal of dangerous creatures in the
ministry of magic McNair's personality
was cruel evil bloodthirsty and
malicious he was ruthless and often took
pleasure in his job as an executioner
during the battle of the Department of
mysteries he even attempted to brutally
strangle Harry Potter but was stopped by
Neville Longbottom who poked him in the
eye with Hermione Granger's wand
Draco Malfoy son of Lucius Malfoy was a
conflicted young wizard that acted as
Harry's rival and one of the main
antagonists throughout the story
characterized by arrogant snobbishness
and a sense of entitlement Draco chose
to embrace the beliefs of his family and
joined the Death Eaters at a relatively
young age while not directly involved in
any significant battles Draco plays a
notable role as a Death Eater when he's
assigned the task of assassinating Albus
Dumbledore something which she
ultimately fails to do in terms of
magical ability however Draco was quite
gifted at a young age he was given a
wand made of Hawthorne a material which
is only ever placed in the hands of a
talented young witch or wizard he also
received additional training from his
powerful Aunt Bellatrix after joining
the ranks of the Death Eaters
rodolf is the strange husband of
Bellatrix Lestrange played a significant
role as a Death Eater and fought in both
the first and second Wizarding Wars in
terms of personality rodolfus is
depicted as very loyal to Voldemort and
fully committed to the cause of pure
blood Supremacy he was also known to
have a particularly cruel and ruthless
nature this is well showcased by his
torture of Frank and Alice Longbottom in
the first Wizarding war rodolfus was
considered to be one of Voldemort's top
Death Eaters taking part in a multitude
of different battles over the course of
both Wars he was skilled in the dark
arts as well as martial magic however he
was notably bastard by his niece
nymphadora Tonks during the battle of
the seven Potters Mal's Super Junior
santu malsabi Senior one of the original
Death Eaters was a dark wizard that
joined Voldemort's cause in the second
Wizarding War as a boy he attended
Hogwarts at the same time as Severus
Snape Lily Potter and the Marauders with
Lily once remarking that he was creepy
and had an evil sense of humor he was
notably paired with Lucius Malfoy during
the battle of the Department of
mysteries according to Igor kakarov what
set mulsabi Jr apart from others was his
extreme Proficiency in performing the
imperious curse the unforgivable curse
allows you to control others apparently
this curse which allowed him to force
people to do horrific things was his
specialty
Augustus Rookwood was one of Voldemort's
most formidable allies and by the time
of the second Wizarding War one of his
oldest Rookwood served a unique role
within the rank of the Death Eaters it
was a mole within the ministry of magic
of course for Voldemort to succeed in
his campaigns against his fellow Wizards
he needed to lure many influential
Ministry workers to his cause but
Augustus was special because he worked
in the department of mysteries the very
place that held the secrets of thought
love time and death Rookwood notably
took on Kingsley shacklebolt one on one
during the battle of the Department of
mysteries though Rook would last his
ability to hold his own for any amount
of time with the wizard as powerful as
Kingsley is a testament to his power he
was also able to take on a massive group
of students all by himself during the
Battle of Hogwarts
Lucius Malfoy father of Draco and
husband to Narcissa black was one of
Voldemort's most trusted supporters
fulfilling his role as a Death Eater in
but the first and second Wizarding Wars
during the first visiting War Lucius
bravely battled against the Dark Lord's
foes as his top Lieutenant guiding
portions of the dark Forces the combat
he fearlessly faced trained auras and
members of the Order of the Phoenix
proving his strength and skill in the
face of battle he is known for his
manipulation cunning and his desire to
maintain the social and political
standing of his family
Lucius is often seen as a cold and
calculating individual using his wealth
and influence to further his own
interests in terms of power I would say
that Lucius is one of the most
underrated something which I feel can be
partially attributed to his sometimes
cowardly Behavior Peter Pettigrew was a
former order and Order of the Phoenix
member that defected during the first
Wizarding War instead joining
Voldemort's cause and becoming a Death
Eater batter crew was known for his weak
and cowardly personality a wizard that
was easily influenced and gravitated
towards those he perceived as powerful
and capable of protecting him because
patoku was untalented as a boy and
because he had such a cowardly
personality many people mislabel him as
a weak wizard however this is just not
the case Pettigrew could easily wield
the killing curse produce powerful
blasting curses strong enough to destroy
hundreds of feet of sewer system create
highly Advanced potions transfigure
himself conjure objects out of thin air
and more was he a bit of a sniveling
coward yes but was he a powerful sibling
coward certainly regulus black was a
pure blood Wizard and member of the
famous black family he was the son of
Orion and woolberger black and the
younger brother of Sirius Black in his
youth regulus idolized Voldemort which
led to his eventual transformation into
a Death Eater however regulus later
defected when he found out what Lord
Voldemort was capable of doing in order
to achieve his goals regulus was an
extremely intelligent Wizard and had he
not sacrificed his life would have
perhaps been one of the good guys most
valuable weapons against evil he was
also a very talented young wizard with a
very promising future Corbin yaxley was
known for his dedication to serving Lord
Voldemort and his commitment to the
ideals of the Death Eaters he served
Voldemort during birth the first and
second Wizarding Wars his personality
exhibited ruthlessness tenacity tea and
a deep loyalty to the Dark Lord's cause
as head of the Department of magical law
enforcement under Voldemort takeover he
used his position to persecute
muckleborns and enforce the oppressive
regime during the second Wizarding war
yaksley was tasked with a variety of
missions including the collection of
horror Slughorn who Voldemort need to be
extremely powerful as well as the
capturing of Hermione Granger's parents
based on the difficulty of the tasks
that he was given I think we can
reasonably assume that yaxley was quite
a powerful dark wizard yaxley was
notably gifted at the imperius curse
something which he used to control Pie's
thickness for the duration of the war
thorfin Ralph's dark Wizard and Death
Eater he had a large frame with blonde
hair and was known for his role as one
of Voldemort's henchmen participating in
several key battles during the second
Wizarding War Rao's personality was
mainly defined by his cruelty and sadism
which he exhibited on numerous occasions
but where Raul really shined was in his
dueling ability during the battle of the
astronomy Tower Raul proved his skill as
a duelist holding his ground against
nymphadora Tonks while casting curses
left and right he also posed a growth
threat to rumors Lupine nearly taking
him down but instead missing and killing
fellow Death Eater Gibbon throughout the
battle Raul rigged Havoc keeping members
of the Order of the Phoenix and
Dumbledore's Army at Bay allowing his
allies to corner a weakened Albus
Dumbledore miraculously he emerged from
the battle mostly unharmed Evan Rosier
was the son of Rozier senior one of the
earliest Death Eaters Evan fought
fiercely for Voldemort over the course
of the first Wizarding war and proved to
be a force to be reckoned with over the
course of this War Death Eaters were
fiercely pursued by auras one of which
was a prime Aleister Moody making the
landscape quite treacherous for dark
wizards one day Rosier was caught by
Moody but not without a fight during
Moody's capture of the dark wizard
Rosier was able to blast off a
significant part of Moody's nose in the
struggle given that Moody generally
tried to avoid killing his enemies it
suggests that Rozier was simply too
dangerous to try and capture alive the
fact that Evan was able to give Moody
the most powerful Aura of all time such
a hard time points to the fact that Evan
was quite powerful in his own right ikor
kakarov was a pure blood Wizard and
Death Eater that later became Headmaster
of durmstrang Institute kakarov has a
very dark past and when he was a young
Death Eater he would torture Muggles
along with Antonin dolahov and others in
terms of his personality kakarov was a
bit of a snake seemingly flip-flopping
and showing allegiance to whoever
happened to be in power at any given
moment sort of similar to Pettigrew in
the first Wizarding war kakarov was
eventually captured by the famous Aura
Alistair Moody and promptly sent to
Azkaban when the time came for khakarov
to stand trial for his crimes he blurted
out the names of every Death Eater that
he could think of hoping that it would
alleviate his sentence by giving the
ministry the name Augustus Rookwood the
ministry took leniency with karoth and
he was eventually released from Azkaban
it was shortly after his release that he
assumed the position of Headmaster at
durmstrang B being that kakarov was the
Headmaster of a Wizarding school I'd be
willing to bet that he possessed
considerable magical ability Antonin
dolahov was one of Floyd Voldemort's
most powerful and loyal followers he was
involved in both the first and second
listening Wars and was responsible for
torturing countless monkeys and
non-supporters of the dark lord as far
as dueling is concerned dolahov may have
been one of the most successful dark
Wizards over the course of the two wars
during the battle of the Department of
mysteries he dueled the combo of Harry
Potter Hermione Granger and Neville
Longbottom single-handedly despite a
silencing charm forcing him to use all
non-verbal magic shortly after he
defeated and injured Alistair Madame
moody in a tool though he did not kill
him he then went on to duel the powerful
Sirius Black with whom he was able to
hold his own dolov's perhaps most
humiliating moment was when he was put
face to face with Ron Hermione and Harry
in London Hermione was able to take
control of the situation and put
dollarhoff in a full body bind curse
however the famous Trio have been able
to accomplish some amazing things
together so I'm really not too surprised
Barty Crouch Jr was a Death Eater and
Son of Ministry of magic official
bartimius Crouch senior Grouch Jr has a
rich history with the Death Eaters
joining them as early as his teenage
years in his earlier years Barty Crouch
Jr was responsible for torturing
Neville's parents and Powerful auras
Frank and Alice Longbottom he was also
instrumental in Voldemort's Resurgence
Crouch Jr is most well known for
kidnapping and imprisoning the powerful
Mad Eye Moody then teaching at Hogwarts
School for an entire year in his stand I
don't know what's more impressive
capturing mad eye or teaching for an
entire school year undetected in my
opinion Crouch may be one of the most
underrated Wizards in all of history
Bellatrix Lestrange was one of if not
Voldemort's most loyal follower she was
a frightening pure blood witch that came
from the black family a long line of
powerful witches and wizards with a
twisted agenda Bellatrix was one of the
most powerful people in The Wizarding
World period responsible for killing a
number of wizards including Sirius Black
belatrix was a known proponent of the
cruciatus curse and had considerable
knowledge in the realm of the dark arts
Bellatrix was eventually defeated by
Molly Weasley which I think was really
just the result of her not taking Molly
seriously her confidence was
over-inflated and she didn't focus when
the two were dueling laughing
hysterically throughout Molly and full
motherly protective mode bastard
Bellatrix and she was never to be seen
again last but not least we have Severus
Snape Snape knew more curses when he
arrived at school than half the kids in
seventh year and he was part of a gang
of slytherins who nearly all turned out
to be Death Eaters the Snape is widely
considered to be one of the most gifted
Wizards in the entire Harry Potter
series his skills are only really
outmatched by Voldemort Dumbledore and
Grindelwald who are in a bit of class of
their own but Snape's extremely powerful
nonetheless during his time at Hogwarts
Snape assumed the identity the
Half-Blood Prince and scribbled all
sorts of spell Creations into his copy
of advanced potion making among these
spells was the powerful and vicious
sectum sempra
Snape can also fly and is one of only
two known Wizards who are capable of
doing this the other being Voldemort
when Snape Jewels McGonagall in the film
he is clearly holding back but matching
an extremely powerful McGonagall
nonetheless this is similar to the scene
in the ministry Atrium where Dumbledore
is holding back against Voldemort but to
a more significant degree
Snape is also cited as saying that
Voldemort is the most accomplished
legitimens the world has ever seen which
would mean that him being able to keep
Voldemort out of his mind would in a way
make him one of the most professed
aquamans there's truly no telling what
Snape would have been able to accomplish
if he had lived a more linear life and I
can confidently say that he was the most
powerful of the Death Eaters and that
concludes today's video do you agree
with my rankings let me know what your
top 10 20 or 30 would look like down in
the comment section below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live foreign